[MUSIC PLAYING]
BUZZ HAYS: We're going to be
talking about revolutionizing
media workflows through what we
refer to as intelligent content
discovery.
So we'll walk you through this.
And we have some demonstrations
and other exciting things,
but first a little
housekeeping here.
We have three speakers today.
We have Bryan Rutkowski, who
is a Customer Engineer in Media
for Google Cloud.
We have Drew Hodon,
who's a Machine Learning
Specialist with Google Cloud.
My name is Buzz Hayes,
I'm the Global Lead
of Media Entertainment Solutions
for the Google Cloud Solutions
Architecture Team.
Quickly, our agenda for today--
we're going to start
with an overview of what
this notion of intelligent
content is all about.
We'll give you a walkthrough,
some of the steps to how
that solution is put together.
We'll talk about
how this applies
to archives and online or
cold storage in the cloud.
We'll also be talking quite a
bit about the use of AI and ML
tools for media.
You'll have a demo of
one of our partner tools
that surfaces in a very
elegant visual fashion,
will surface machine
learning data, metadata,
that makes it very easy
to search your content.
We'll also be doing a
discussion about how Discovery--
our pals at Discovery,
thank you for being here--
are using intelligent content
in their monstrous archive--
and awesome archive,
I should say.
And we'll also
tell you how to get
started on this whole process.
For those of you who
have the Next App,
if you go to this
particular session,
you'll find a link for Dory.
So if you have any questions,
feel free to enter it there.
We also have microphones here.
So feel free at the end-- we'll
have some time for Q & A--
to step up to the mic
and ask the questions.
So without further
ado, let's take
a look at what intelligent
content is all about.
So we're going to take a top
view here of the process.
It starts with
consolidating the media.
You've got media in
all sorts of places
and in all sorts of
forms, so you really
want to bring that all
into a single platform,
or at least a similar platform.
It may be cloud, but it may
be multi-cloud, in this case.
But you want to put all
your assets together,
then you want to apply
machine learning tools.
And we have a lot
of automated tools
now that are not
only easy to use,
but they're also easy to
modify, which is great.
And Drew will get into some
of that in a little bit.
But this allows you
to gain new insights
and apply metadata to both
your audio and visual data.
That includes documents
and photographs, as well.
And then once your
content has intelligence,
basically, you have the
power of your entire archive
at your fingertips.
A lot of archives
right now don't
exist in a meaningfully
searchable form.
And we'll get into why
that is in a minute.
But ultimately, you want to
be able to find everything
that's in there and leverage
that for whatever purpose.
So the vast majority
of media archives,
especially at the Hollywood
studios and television
entities, exist in a form
that can't even be viewed,
let alone monetized.
So we have some solutions to
help figure that out, as well.
And then once the library is
made meaningfully searchable
by adding the metadata using the
machine learning and AI tools,
you can begin to broaden
your use of these tools
to gain further
insights and derive
analytics from that content,
which can be very important.
And so it increases
the level of insight
you have into this content
pretty dramatically.
So let's go a little
bit deeper into this.
Here's how it works.
You're basically starting by
adjusting the content into GCS,
into cloud storage.
And the content can come
from a variety places,
whether it's already
on some spinning disk
someplace on a server, some
physical storage, like tape,
for example, a data tape.
It could also be videotape.
It could be film, other things.
But they have to be
digitized, obviously.
So once all of those
assets are available,
you ingest those, import
those into Cloud Storage.
And then using a variety
of the GCP tools,
we can then apply all of
the various relevant tools
to derive these insights.
So whether you're trying to
derive visual information
from images, you're trying
to derive speech from audio,
you're trying to derive
text from images,
a variety of things
can be leveraged,
and mostly automatically,
which is great.
And then you can start
to visualize that data
through various ways.
And you'll have a demo,
again, in a few minutes,
of one of the
partner solutions we
have for visualizing that data.
How many of you use media
asset management software
at this point?
Yeah?
How many do you absolutely
love the tool you have?
[LAUGHTER]
Wait.
I don't see any hands.
Something's wrong.
OK, it was once asked
to me by a studio client
why media asset
management can't be
as simple as a Google search.
And the beauty of the
Intelligent Content Discovery
is that it can be as
simple as a Google search.
You want to be able to
ask questions the way
the humans who are looking for
the answers are asking them--
that scene with the
woman in the blue
dress, and she
said good morning.
She had a hat.
You know, that kind of thing--
you want to be able to surface
meaningful data from even
obtuse queries like that.
And then once you have that,
you can activate this content
in a variety of different ways.
And I think there are many gold
mines sitting out there that
are yet to be explored,
just because they
don't have meaningful
metadata attached to them.
So there are a number of
different formats out there.
And apologies to any of you who
are die-hard supporters of any
of these formats I'm about
to dis here a little bit.
But it's difficult to find
insights in your content
if it's sitting on some
physical media that
hasn't been brought into
a platform like Cloud
to be able to analyze it.
So you're still talking
about a lot of LTO tape,
or some form of data tape.
And as many of you
know, a tape in it
itself is not
inherently archival.
I guess it depends on your
definition of archival.
If you talk to
LTO manufacturers,
they'll probably tell
you that the tape
will last 35 years, which
is true if you don't use it.
And then if you
start to use it, you
start getting wear and tear.
That shelf life ends up
getting much, much smaller.
So you really rely on
the physical storage.
And luckily, we
have great partners
like Iron Mountain who do a
very good job of climate control
and things for
physical asset media.
But it really requires
diligence to make sure
that that data is still good.
And you have to check it.
Also with LTO, you tend
to have to migrate it
to whatever the newest format
is, because most of these LTO
formats are not backward
compatible more than maybe
a version.
So you end up with significant
physical damage possibilities--
bit rot, for example, if it
hasn't been checked in a while.
So there's a number
of reasons why
LTO is becoming a
bit more problematic,
especially given the volume
of content that we have now.
It's almost too much.
Major studios will migrate their
entire collections to new LTO
formats every few years.
And it's becoming prohibitively
expensive to do that.
The manual tagging of assets--
you know, a lot of people
have been applying metadata.
The term's been around forever.
And they've been
using human resources
to do that, which is great.
It's a bit error prone
because, if you have 50 humans,
they're going to be
interpreting things differently.
They're not all going to give
the same results on things.
Plus, it's a little
bit error prone.
And you're basically
having to watch
things, transcribe things.
And really, it requires a
lot of paying attention.
And there's so much
content that it's
almost impossible
for human beings
to do all this transcription.
So that's another reason
why using something
like Intelligent Content
Discovery makes a lot of sense.
You also find in
this day and age,
if you're working
especially in feature films,
you have day and date
releases of films
that have to go out in multiple
formats to dozens of countries.
I was talking with an
executive at Disney.
And one of the latest
Marvel releases
went out in over 100
versions on the same day.
So there's a lot of content
that has to be taken care of,
and some of that content has to
be filtered because there are
certain regional requirements.
You know, there are
censorship boards
in various parts of the country
that have very strict rules.
There's often inappropriate
content for various audiences.
There's other things
that has to be trapped
before it goes out there.
So compliance is a big issue.
And so using ML tools
to automatically derive
that those insights can be very
helpful, especially when you
have these massive
volumes of content.
And again, to find
that traditionally,
the inappropriate
content, required a person
having to sit there and find it.
So what if you knew
what your content knows?
So the idea is if
you're consistently
applying the same tools
and the same metadata,
you're surfacing
the same metadata
for your entire
library, you're going
to find consistency is
actually of great benefit.
You'll see in this
demo in a few minutes
that you can now surface
things that are like something
you found.
So if you found something
you really like,
by having consistent
metadata, you
can also surface
other things just
like that, which can be
very, very useful when
you're trying to leverage the
assets in your media library.
So it makes the entire library,
the life of that library,
considerably longer if you find
that you can use these insights
to leverage licensing.
A lot of studios now are finding
that they have great revenue
in stock footage--
footage that's not
used in the film,
but they shot it for the film.
It's not unusual for film
to have a very high shooting
ratio these days because
of digital technology.
It used to be when we shot film,
we'd shoot a 10 to 1 ratio.
For every minute of
screen time, there'd
be 10 minutes of capture.
Nowadays it's, not unusual
to have 200 or 300 to 1.
So there's a lot of content that
never makes it into the movie.
So why not monetize that?
But you have to know
where it is first.
So obviously, we want
to be able to reduce
the time it takes to do this.
You need to prepare the
content for your distribution.
So we can apply
these tools again
to find sensitive
content, to derive
closed captioning, for
example, a number of things.
We want optimize the content
and adhere to whatever
compliance process there is.
Every country has different
restrictions on that.
And again, we want to create
rich and consistent metadata.
That's the key.
So as the value that comes
with intelligent media
content is to really
understand how
to make meaningfully
searchable metadata.
It's easy to surface metadata
that's not very useful.
We want to make sure
that it is useful.
And we provide labels as
part of that to identify
certain objects in the frame.
And then we can then search
our content very quickly
and cost effectively.
We can also provide
intelligence search capabilities
for media archives and enable
consumers to find their content
very quickly and easily.
And that's important,
especially in this day and age
with deadlines
being what they are.
You also reduce fines
and risks, of which
they are very real when it
comes to inappropriate content.
And you can find new ways
to monetize this content
through the information
that's derived.
So let's take a quick
look here at the steps
on our way to the solution.
As you can see
here, basically, you
identify the right partner
to get the data out
of your data or your
physical library.
And in many cases, some of
the tools that we have you
can do that yourself, or you can
partner with one of our partner
companies to do that.
You ingest your
archives into GCP.
We have partners that
specialize in that, as well.
We have partners that help you
migrate your tape libraries--
your data tape libraries.
We have other partners
that will help
your take your physical assets,
like videotape and film,
and migrate those
into the platform.
And then you can generate the
insights from our Google Cloud
ML tools in a variety
of ways, which
we'll talk about a little bit.
And then once you've got that,
you can organize it and make
it all accessible, which is
really quite simple, again,
because of the consistency
aspect through the metadata.
And then you really get
some meaningful insights
into these tools.
And that's the important
thing about most archives,
because we haven't had the
luxury of that in a while.
So here's some of the media
partners that we have.
And this is by no means
an exhaustive list--
but from connectivity
to data migration,
to the ML and AI tools, to
actual content management.
And the list is
growing every day.
And all of these
are vital components
to the ecosystem of the
Intelligent Content Discovery
process.
So very quickly, by moving your
media assets into the cloud,
you'll have unprecedented
control over that content.
However, there's many different
types of media archives.
And most of them
are not digital.
According to the Academy
of Motion Picture Arts
and Sciences, half of the films
made prior to 1950 no longer
exist in any form.
And that's just because
of neglect and the fact
that it wasn't really
considered something
that people would need to hold
onto until it was too late.
So we're trying to curb that.
And videotape is even worse.
And I think we're about to
realize that in a few years
when we start to go back
to these older archives
and realize we can't
read the data anymore.
So this analog content is
really important to us.
So we've been working
with media archives
all over the world
to help come up
with solutions to get all
of the content digitized
and make it intelligently
searchable, so that then it
can be brought to market,
if that's the intention,
or preserved, which is another
intention of a lot of older
material, but at least be
able to make this content more
stable and searchable.
And then by applying
media search,
we can do really cool
things, like just entering
a line of dialogue, or
the name of an actor
and actress, or even
their character name,
or what they're
wearing in a scene,
or the location where
they are, and be
able to surface very quickly
the visual content that relates
to those searches, that
are asked in human terms,
not in Boolean search
terms, for example.
So if you're using the
power of Google Cloud,
you can definitely find
what you and your audience
is looking for by
applying this data.
So with this huge variety
of both digital and physical
assets, we need more
and more efficient
solutions to be able to
migrate this to Cloud.
And that's sort of key in all of
this is getting stuff in there
quickly.
Here's quickly some overviews
of storage solutions.
Of course, we have a variety
of different use cases here.
And so we have streaming video.
We have video transcoding,
backup, archival disaster
recovery, to mention just a few.
And we have different storage
classes for all those,
as you're probably all aware.
We also yesterday announced
a new cold line storage
tier, which is arguably
less expensive than tape,
which is great.
This is for data that's
accessed far less
than what you would normally
use for regional storage.
So it's important
to note that you
have different levels of storage
for all of the different media
needs you have.
So it's important
through all of this
that when you're trying
to derive the insights
from this metadata, that it's
put into a useful form where
you can actually read
it and make sense of it.
And I think it's
really important
to know that there are
tools out there that
currently do this for you.
I don't know if any of you have
seen the output of just an ML
process, but
typically, it's just
a gigantic JSON file
with a ton of text
and numbers and brackets in it.
And it's not the most
friendly thing to work with.
So to show a little bit more
about how these insights can
be leveraged, I want to
introduce Drew Hodun, who's
going to walk you
through the machine
learning and AI aspects of the
intelligent content discovery.
Drew?
DREW HODUN.
Awesome.
Thank you, Buzz.
So let's talk a little bit
more about the capabilities
we can implement on our content
once it's in the Cloud--
once we have it in a more
usable, accessible format.
So within Google Cloud,
we provided a variety
of different ways to
use machine learning
from off-the-shelf APIs,
all the way to the latest
and greatest in machine learning
researcher and data science
tools.
We're going to focus mainly
on the off-the-shelf APIs--
the models that Google builds
and maintains using Google
sized data, sets and
Google expertise.
In particular, for
the media archives
that we're talking about, our
Vision API and our Video API
are critical first steps
to tagging your data.
We'll talk about a lot
of different things
that you can get
out of these APIs.
It's worth noting that
you can call these APIs
with a single RESTful call.
You don't need to have
a tremendous amount
of compute in Google Cloud
or a tremendous amount of ML
expertise.
It's very easy to add these
into existing applications.
So these APIs will--
I'll talk about some
of the methods--
but detect a lot of predefined
labels in the models
that we build.
But you'll notice up here,
we have AutoML Vision, AutoML
Video, which we just announced.
These are really
powerful capabilities
that allow you to
define what you're
looking for in your content.
You need to provide
some training data,
and we'll tell we'll show you
a really easy way to do that.
But then you can run these
AutoML APIs on your data
and get the tags
and the information
that you care
about, not the tags
that that's part of just
the Google taxonomy, right?
That's something we hear
a lot from customers
is the off-the-shelf APIs
that they see across Google
and other providers
are nice, but they
have really specific things
are looking to detect.
And they have on the
ground expertise--
producers, et cetera,
who are looking
for very specific things, but
aren't ML experts or maybe even
developers.
And so we'll show how
we can integrate that.
Here are a lot of
different things
you can do with the APIs.
It's not just limited to
vision or video, right?
There's all the
standard metadata
tagging we get with our
video and vision APIs.
We're doing things like logo
detection, landmark detection.
We'll actually tell you
latitude and longitude
if we recognize a landmark.
We'll recognize
faces and sentiments.
And this is sort of the backbone
of your Smart Media Archive,
is just all the tags you
get-- what is in the frame,
on the screen.
We can also use speech to text.
So this is transcription.
If you have an audio file, or
there's audio in your video,
we'll output in a
highly accurate manner
what is being said.
If there's multiple
speakers, not an issue.
We can handle that, as well.
We do translation.
So this is part of that
localization challenge, right?
How do we create
translated transcriptions
of what's going on?
How do we make our
content searchable
in multiple languages?
Even if we're not doing
closed captioning using this,
it would be great
to know what's being
said in a video
across many languages
to then make it searchable
and discoverable by our users.
And if you have a relatively
small data set of labeled data
and you want to
improve the API, you
can do that using
AutoML Translate.
You would provide us
your loadable data,
either a dictionary of
word to word, or a sentence
to sentence.
And with a click
of a button, we'll
train an even more
accurate Translation API
just for your
usage, because it's
using your data to improve it.
We can do sentiment extraction
using the Natural Language API.
So is this a generally positive
clip or a generally negative
clip, among other things?
We can classify very
quickly what is in the clip,
like I said.
One of the things that Video
Intelligence API will also do
is shot detection.
So it helps you to
break up your video
and then discover what is
in these different shots
so you can either
quickly find and create
content shot for shot,
or in some cases,
I've worked with customers
to actually generate
content on-the-fly,
using techniques
like the shot detection.
So let's dive a
little bit deeper
into the Video Intelligence
API and the AutoML Video API
and talk about the
methods we have.
So with a single
API, you can tell
us to run one or all of
these ML passes on your data.
So there's the label detection.
And that's, what are we seeing?
What are the actions
that are happening?
What's on screen?
We'll do text detection or OCR.
So if there's any text on
screen, you'll get that.
And that's really valuable
from a search standpoint.
Logo detection-- really
important if you're
looking for content
to build a partnership
or understand how often
a partner is on screen.
We'll do speech transcription.
So even though you're
sending the video,
so it's audio and video,
we'll do the transcription
as part of that
single API call, which
makes that a lot easier
for you to implement.
Explicit content
detection is critical--
so understanding
what is on screen,
when it might be more
sensitive, in particular,
for localization.
Different markets care
about different aspects
of explicit content
detection, whether it's
violence, adult
content, et cetera.
And we mentioned the
shot change detection.
All of this can be done
with a single API call.
Huge amount of information
you get back on your content.
So some new announcements with
the Video Intelligence API,
in particular.
We used to just offer
batch mode, which
was you had a video file
on Google Cloud Storage,
you would call the API and
point the API at that file.
We now support file streaming.
So let's say you
have a large file.
You can create a GRPC
streaming connection
and send that, basically
byte for byte, up to the API.
You don't need to
land that in GCS.
Obviously, a lot of
workflows-- and the workflow
we're talking about
recommends that you
have the content on GCS.
But let's say you have either
a real time situation or a use
case where the
file is elsewhere,
and you don't want
to move it, right?
We support that now.
And I mentioned real time.
We now support live streaming.
So we support HLS,
RTSP, and RTMP.
Great for understanding
live content--
what's being said,
what's on screen.
Super helpful if you're
doing custom ad placement--
just-in-time ad placement.
In the prefetch, for
example, on online content,
you can know in real
time what's on screen
and do quite a lot with that.
So we're going to
show you a demo using
one of our several partners on
the ML Video Intelligence end.
We're going to be using Zuora
Video Intelligence platform--
ZVI.
So ZVI, as you'll
see in a, second it's
a really intuitive
front end GUI.
It's the back end
document model.
And it also applies some custom
ML and clustering ML, as well.
It's a really easy way to use
all these APIs in an accessible
manner.
No coding required.
And you'll see just how powerful
the combination of these two
technologies are.
So behind the scenes how the
solution is going to work--
first, you'd import the
assets into Google Cloud, then
index them.
There's a clipifying process
where we create proxies.
So you might have
a two-hour file,
but we'll create three
five-second clips
of that content.
Just proxies, though, so
we're not transcoding.
We're not creating
additional burden there.
Then we can either use the
Google ML APIs off-the-shelf,
or train our own models.
And we'll actually
show you both.
We'll run all those ML
passes over the content,
and then you'll have
the search capability
across your entire archive.
So here's the
architecture you just saw.
This is, again, in
this case, we're
using Zuora as the front end.
But we have a number
of different partners.
We've seen build some
similar solutions themselves.
And this is the order--
importing the assets,
creating the proxies
and indexing, training
models, running the models.
And then ultimately, you get
a very intelligent archive
that you can then use to
find content to build that
into your production workflow.
There's quite a lot
you can do with this.
All right, so here we are
in the Zuora interface.
We have gone ahead and--
I need to refresh.
So we have already run the
clipification process and all
the ML passes across our data.
So we have a data set--
maybe this is a data set
that you don't really
know what's in there.
This is one of the
powerful things we find out
is you might have a ton of
data and not even understand
what's in your archive.
We've seen this time and
again with customers.
So each clip we've
run the ML passes on.
So we can see here, if I
select this clip, metadata
on the left.
We have all sorts of
creative analysis.
We have all the different
tags we pulled from the API.
So we've actually detected some
faces and pulled some values
of the sentiment we see.
Here are all the different tags
that we pulled out of the API.
And as Buzz mentioned,
you get quite a lot
of data out of these APIs.
So one of the powerful things
of a solution like this
is we're not throwing
away tags, we're
just putting it in a database
and making it searchable.
So you're not having
to look at this clip
and look at all 50 tags.
But when you search for it, it
does get a hit, and it's there.
And in this environment,
we've run the Video API,
the Vision API, Speech to Text.
We've done Natural Language.
We've done Sentiment Detection,
and we'll show you Auto ML.
So we've run all these APIs
already on this content.
So now I can do things
like Google style search.
I could search for
a house, right?
And I get different clips
of people's houses--
inside, outside.
Also, some clips
of the White House.
So if I search
White House, that'll
kind of zero in to a
more specific search.
If I do White
House and portrait,
you can see how quickly I
found that specific clip
I was looking for, right?
So this is very natural.
This is how we search.
And by the way, this search
is going across the tags.
It's going across
the speech-to-text.
It combines all
this different data
into a very intuitive interface.
So for example, if
I search "mother"--
I remember that we
had a lot of capture.
There was a
particular time where
someone was talking about
their mother in this very
long interview.
If I run this clip,
we'll actually find out.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --and I'm a quilter,
and I'm a mother.
[END PLAYBACK]
DREW HODUN.
So you kind of
heard what was said.
Within the metadata, we
actually have a transcription
of what was said in this clip.
So now I can combine tech
searches, with tag searches,
with some of the other
capabilities that Zuora
gives you.
So one slick feature that you
get as part of the Zuora front
end is a clustering image
similarity or shot similarity
search.
So I can see here, maybe I
have a shot that's like this.
And I kind of like either the
color, or I like that scene.
I want to find other
shots that are similar.
Ooh, that's not a good one.
Sorry.
[LAUGHS] We'll take this one.
And with that image
similarity search,
I find all of the
other clips that
are similar from a
clustering standpoint.
There's some unstructured
machine learning going on here.
What's cool with
this is the kind of--
I'll talk about what we can
do with that in just a second.
We can see here, we've actually
created some smart searches
using these tags.
So we have lots and lots of
tags in the back end now.
With this interface,
it's really easy
to decide tags we care
about, build a smart search,
and then do things
like, hey, I want
to find all the different angry
clips, where someone's angry.
And maybe combine that
with an actor's name.
So I want all the
angry clips of actor A,
B, or C. I can create
these smart searches,
if I know what I'm
looking for ahead of time.
If I'm not, I just type
into the search bar the way
I've been showing.
We do OCR.
So if there's text
on screen, that
become searchable, as well.
Now, the last thing
I'll show you,
which I think is very slick,
is our AutoML Integration.
So you can upload your content
into Auto ML, train a model,
do that all in the
Google Cloud console.
We have several
partners, including
this, that will actually
integrate with our API.
So you don't even have to go
into Google Cloud yourself
to do this.
So for example, we've built
up a small training set.
You can see I have 13 videos--
13, 12, 11, of
different shot types.
So this is something that
the API was not returning.
It wasn't saying
this is a close-up.
This is a medium close.
This is a full or a long shot.
But this is a tag that I really
care about as an end user,
right?
From a production
workflow standpoint,
I really want to know
what were the shot types.
And maybe we have a
different definition
than someone else might.
So with just a small
amount of data here,
you can see the
different shot types
that have classified--
close-up, full, medium shot.
Right?
We have built-in auto ML model.
And it's pretty easy to do.
You right-click and click, Train
With Auto ML Video or Vision.
Vision would take thumbnails,
build a training set.
And now you have a custom model.
Video will look
a the entire clip
and build a model based on that.
We can see here that,
just from these 13
videos in each category,
when the model got trained,
it was then applied
to the entire archive.
And we can see here I've
identified all the close-up
shots in my archive,
using just 13 examples.
I've identified all the
full shots in my archive,
using just those few examples.
And I can actually
tune the sensitivity
if I want to make it even more
certain that it's a full shot.
Not only that, I can
improve the model over time.
So one of the
things I can do is,
if I identify something that
I don't think is a full shot--
let's see if I can find one--
maybe I say this isn't a
full, this is maybe a medium.
What I can do is take this
clip, I can add it to--
well, all right.
You can very easily
add it into the folders
into that training set, right?
[LAUGHTER]
Live demos, right?
And then you have the new data.
Hit Train With Google
Auto ML Vision.
Without going into
Google Cloud Console,
this data's going
to be uploaded.
You have a training set.
20 minutes later, that
new model gets applied
across all of your archive.
So very easy to consume ML,
even for your producers,
whoever is interacting
with this content.
All right.
So with that, I'm going to
hand it off to Bryan Rutkowski
to walk you through
the next section.
BRYAN RUTKOWSKI: So my
name's Bryan Rutkowski.
I'm a Google Cloud
Customer Engineer.
And I've been working with
Discovery for a little while
now.
And it's really my privilege
to be up here today
because the work we've
been doing with Discovery
is really actually
transforming their content
into intelligent content.
So this is real live production
stuff here against thousands
of hours of content.
So I'm excited to talk
to you about it today.
But before I begin,
could I see a show
of hands of how many people
have used our ML APIs before?
A few of you.
All right.
Great.
Well, hopefully after this,
you'll I'll go out and try it.
But for those of you that
haven't used it before,
like Buzz alluded to,
whenever you run an ML API,
this is what's
returned-- a lot of JSON.
And you can imagine if
you've got thousands
upon thousands of
hours of content,
just imagine how much
JSON you'll get back.
What do you do with that JSON?
How do you get value from it?
How do you normalize it?
How do you store it?
Where do you store it, right?
But probably more importantly,
how do you actually
visualize it?
How do you gain value from
that machine learning?
How do you make your
processes more efficient?
How do you make your workforce
more efficient to save time?
So let's talk about how
Discovery is doing this today.
First, they have a
partner named SDVI--
one of our Google Cloud
Technology partners.
And SDVI has been in this
business for some time now.
They work with large
media companies,
like Discovery, Fox, Sky, and
Turner, as well as others.
And what they do is they focus
on the media supply chain.
They are able to
manage and optimize
the technical applications
in order to process content.
They abstract that
infrastructure that's
needed to do all of this.
And one example is
they can actually
automate the process of running
all the content through our ML
APIs.
So the way that SDVI
describes themselves
as-- they're like
a factory, right?
You're a large media company.
You're getting content in from
producers or other sources.
You've got to do a dozen,
multiple dozens of things
to that content before it's
ready for distribution.
And SDVI really helps automate
that entire workflow for you.
The other key thing is,
how do you actually, again,
make this valuable
to your workforce?
How do really enhance their
abilities to do their work?
And SDVI has a program
called Rally Access, which is
a plug-in for Adobe Premiere.
So this is what
Discovery actually
utilizes to visualize
all of that ML data
in their editing suite.
And what this allows them to
do is things like compliance
and distribution versioning,
metadata tagging,
caption validation,
among many other things.
So let's talk about what
Discovery is doing today.
Discovery is utilizing
our Video Intelligence API
to do labeling, explicit
content detection,
speech-to-text transcription.
And all of those
things are allowing
them to allow their editors
to search for labels right
in Adobe Premier.
It allows them to find
words that people said.
You can search
through that content
and find where
somebody said something
in a piece of content.
And in doing this, it's really
making them more efficient.
They can go in, edit
a video, send it up
to the Cloud for rendering,
and save a lot of time
in that process.
And what it's
doing for Discovery
is enhancing their QC process.
For one content hour, it can
take up to two hours normally
to do a QC.
This is helping them cut that
down to, sometimes, 15 minutes.
So that's a huge savings, right?
But then layer
upon that how many
thousands of upon thousands
of hours of content
come into somebody like
Discovery every year.
And you can immediately
see the massive savings
that Machine Learning
can provide a company.
So at a high level,
this is what we
have helped Discovery build
through the help of SDVI
and Discovery.
You can see on
the left, they are
ingesting content from
multiple data sources.
It gets ingested
into Google Cloud
and stored on our
object storage.
And then they can
run a transcode
on that to create
the proxy file, which
is what's going to be used
to run the ML APIs against.
So you take that proxy file and
run it against each of the APIs
and get all that JSON data back.
And then you store it in
the SDVI Rally database.
And that's where they
normalize the data
and make sure it's in a format
that's ready to be consumed
by an end user.
And then on the
far right, you can
see how somebody on-prem
or anywhere could
go into Adobe Premiere, see
their task orders, their work
orders, and actually start
to edit that content in Adobe
Premiere, pulling that ML
metadata out of the Cloud.
So I'm going to show you
a video of how this looks
in SDVI's Rally Access panel.
So you select your task order.
You can go in and
select the labels
with the time-based
metadata showing up.
On the left, you'll see
that there's actually
time-based metadata for
each label with ins and outs
for that particular label.
So you see they can
select one, and it
shows right on the editing
panel where that video is.
So if you need to search
for some explicit content,
for example, that would take you
right to that point in video.
So you're not
spending time looking
through that entire video trying
to find specific things that
need to be QCed.
So you can also see
in the middle there,
they have the time codes
right in the sequence.
So you can go in and
see exactly as you're
scanning through that
file what the labels are
during that sequence.
So this is what Discovery
is utilizing today,
with the help of SDVI and our
Machine Learning technology.
Now, I want to talk
to you a little bit--
how can you get started
doing this yourself?
And there's really three ways.
One is talk to
your account team,
you know, somebody like me,
a Google Customer Engineer.
And we can help guide
you through this,
give you demos, get you in
touch with partners on how
to build this yourselves.
You can talk to the
partners themselves.
They can show you what their
technology can do and help you.
And then you can engage with
our Professional Services
organization.
And they're the ones
that will actually
come in and help build
this with you, actually
deploy it in your environments.
[MUSIC PLAYING]